Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
As you see here, I love Two Minute Papers, but
fortunately I am not the only one, Elon Musk
loves Two Minute Papers too. What’s more, even
cats love it. Everybody loves Two Minute Papers.
So, what was that? Well, these are all synthetic
videos that were made by this new, magical AI.
So, here, we are adding synthetic data to an
already existing photorealistic video, and the
AI is meant to be able to understand the movement,
facial changes, geometry changes, and track them
correctly and move the moustache, the tattoos, or
anything else properly. That is a huge challenge.
How is that even possible? Many AI-based
techniques from just a year or two ago
were not even close to being able to pull this
off. However, now, hold on to your papers,
and have a look at this new technique, now that
is a great difference. Look at that! So cool!
This is going to be really useful
for at the very least two things.
One, augmented reality applications.
For instance, have a look at this cat. Well, the
bar on the internet for cat videos is quite high,
and this will not cut it. But
wait…yes! Now we’re talking!
The other examples also showcase that the progress
in machine learning and AI research these days
is absolutely incredible. I would like to send a
big thank you to the authors for taking the time
off their busy day to create these results only
for us. That is a huge honor. Thank you so much!
So far, this is fantastic news. Especially
given that many works are limited to one domain,
for instance, for instance, Microsoft’s human
generator technique is limited to people. However,
this works on people, dogs, cats, and even Teslas.
So good. I love it. What a time to be alive!
But wait, I promised two applications,
not one. So, what is the other one?
Well, image editing. Image editing? Really? What
about that? That is not that new…but…aha! Not just
image editing, but mass scale image editing!
Everybody can get antlers, tattoos, stickers, you
name it. We just chuck in the dataset of images,
choose the change that we wish to make, and out
comes the entirety edited dataset automatically.
Now that is a fantastic value proposition.
But, of course, you, the seasoned
Fellow Scholar immediately knows,
that surely, not even this technique is
perfect. So, where are the weak points? Look.
Oh yes, that. I see this issue for nearly
every technique that takes on this task.
It still has troubles with
weird angles and occlusions.
But, we also have good news. If you can navigate
your way around an online Colab notebook,
you can try it too! You know what to
do. Yes, let the experiments begin!
So, what would you use this for? Who would
rock the best moustache? And, what do you
expect to happen a couple more papers down the
line? Please let me know in the comments below.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!